[Applaus]
das ist der perfekte biester ich finde
jetzt immer noch treffen er kocht das x
raid system passiert bei dem jung ist
[Musik]
hier weil er sehr fern darunter netz
bekommen zu diesem video mit sturm und
mit max von leute wir erwarten heute
youtuber an tieren sprechen
ich habe einige sprüche rausgesucht
leute aus allen jahren hätten sie die
ganz alten markt bedienen sturm ja wir
gucken wie es auf einem jahr hätte ich
gern gar nicht eben mal alles klar
erster spruch weil der dieb und wem
stammt der spruch klar ich dich dich
dann buchen sohn und wickelte es nicht
hauptkritikpunkte phase der markterfolg
nächstes vorhin also ich ließ die wörter
im alten vor der st
mehr als 98 sowie ist das buch kommt
jetzt zum kader der sechziger vom
geliebten zahl alles klar welches genau
so folgen einstehen haben doch gewusst
das wird ein spiel werden
ich schreibe und dkv mal ein kleiner und
alles klar denken aber gesund
so heißt es nicht mag das wort nicht
gesprochen ist das wenn wir das eben
nicht mit leeren händen da
doch die sind gericht aber das mögt oder
soll ich gerade ist was wirklich so
schlimm nach schärding so alten station
künster bin unbedingt schon deutet auf
eine mine
er wird heute dem text soll die
schülerzahl hoch war auch wenn drauf
super und design coesfeld richtig gesagt
von krankhafter sowie eine stylische
spruch geht gerne zwei zurück in der
zeit und zwar das geld das war das war
so das war vater sagte levels die
bessere story dazu erzählten wie das
passiert ist sagte deiss das könne das
problem
alles klappt nicht so leitete willst du
mich aufnehmen
neben ein paar das das ist absurd dass
sie direkt schon so ein paar ganz ohne
wissen der garten red oder du sollst du
kleiner oder douglas 1
okay ich hab mich auch essen zu gefeiert
und wir müssen noch mal zum affen
abtreten das heißt nicht vorher alles
klar sollte nächste leyen ist die rede
wir dürfen nicht googeln ich bin jetzt
kennt ihr das beigebracht wird hat das
leise zu 1000 st ich bin jetzt eure
bilderbuch heute ohren spitzen einmal
kurz die hand in den mund
jetzt also vorkampf doch er ist nicht
alleine ist letztes jahr ein mieses jahr
aber dieses bild noch nie da aber diese
sind noch dieses jahr
richtig kennt echt nix von marcel mann
ich habe mir keine dinger das war doch
was ist kein highlight ist eine der
wenigen wirklich eine million paar nice
oder das andere ok heute wird es wieder
gefeiert dann wird wohl die praxis
gehört jedoch der folge was das jeder
abdecken
ich habe mir jetzt aber meint